you look bad TAS thank you so do you um
it's been a while it's been a minute
this is surreal
this is wild I am just feeling like okay
she's Creek finally getting the
attention and love and respect it
deserves
all these nominations it's been insane I
feel like for a show and it's fit the
season to receive an Emmy nomination its
first Emmy nomination is like wild this
is for most of us and the whole cast is
here it's our first Emmys so if you just
see people aimlessly wandering around
the carpet it's probably someone from my
show and you know it's a it's basically
been a whole weekend of me running up to
people I love and screaming at them and
that's been it's been amazing is there a
part of you that's thinking how are we
ending the show now oh I know we've shot
it it's all done it's all put to bed I
know exactly how it ends and I'm happy
with it and I feel like we'll cross our
fingers once it comes out next year but
I feel like we really tried to honor the
show and the fans give the fans what
they want but also end on a note that
feels really true to the show that we
set out to make in the first place
so that's all you can really ask for and
you know
at this point if we can get back here
next year that's I guess we've set a bar
for ourselves yeah yeah obviously we
love you guys but is there a chance
there's gonna be a spinoff of any kind I
have absolutely no idea to be perfectly
honest I am about to wrap our
post-production on our last season and
then the world is my oyster and we'll
see what-what I can shuck from it what
are the chances you're gonna work with
your dad again or are you just tad I
would love to I would love to wear with
our entire cast I want to make another
show that I could just hire them all on
and then just do it again just a
different place different people you
look great congratulations me I miss you